welcome to your mom's house
what is this here we have talks of shit
yeah what is this we're gonna see crazy
looks reaction we're going to show him
should I fast forward that yeah
what's happening around you I guess they
showed him oh oh where did that go
they showed him the song right yeah
pushing so somebody made a crazy love
song great no no with crazy looks mute
music so they basically edited right
they helped it I mean that's one way of
putting it I was saying oh oh sorry the
right way to say that yeah I was saying
that they you know you know you know I'm
saying song but okay what I'm saying is
that the song they played it for him
in front of him so we get to see him
react no way to his own music this is
awesome we never get to see this part
we're getting we're gonna see crazy
looks reaction we're gonna show him his
remix on Segura's podcast okay only tour
I can't decide I'd love for you guys to
comment on it so we'll do that stewey
thanks a lot here is okay crazy low
pushing made nice didn't going on
he's rapping over the song
I love it chuckles out to the fans and a
body you know sighing thanks for the
support to a body like a being saying
hey I keep it pushing and God bless Chia
he loves it
can't tell you what crazy looks I feel
like he's finally getting the attention
he deserves yeah I feel like your mom's
house I was really facilitated that for
him I think we've created yet another
star it is a star we broke Thursday Lane
we broke Peter cane we broke on T V V
LinkedIn is how fuck now we've broken
crazy blokes you know how many stars
have come out of your mom's house it is
ridiculous